if you set a goal for yourself for me  there's only two questions is this  something that you want and are you  going to have fun along the journey  along the way instead of sitting there  thinking about it and stressing about it  and thinking about everything that's  that could potentially stop you or  hinder you just make sure it's what you  want make sure you're going to have fun  and then just rock and roll with it get  started start surrounding yourself with  with the people that are that are going  to help you the people that might have  the knowledge that you need to  accomplish that goal  um start you know utilizing your time  it's all utilizing all those tools that  the universal tools that we all have we  have people we have time all of us have  these things some of us may have a  little more than others but that doesn't  matter you have time for what you what  you make time for man